boundaries is the book dr. Henry cloud
is the author along with dr. John John
Townsend Henry is with us here in the
studio he's one of our speakers at the
smart conference in Dallas along with
Andy Andrews Emmerich's Emerson egg rich
and Meg makers this is a dream team some
of the top speakers and thought leaders
in their fields in America today these
are people that have something to say
and their best-selling books have proven
it and they're the quality world class
on the stage I got to tell you if I was
Henry and I were just talking at the
break my wife Sharon is coming as an
attendee because she wants to see all
these people she can get rip when I'm
speaking but she wants to see all these
people right she's heard all my stuff I
feel your pain there's not a speaker in
America they didn't have a preacher's -
they yeah I preach to me right yeah
that's the wife so same thing but so you
know this stuff really does I think the
reason I give away so many of the books
is it really does penetrate the subject
of money and financial peace right to
have boundaries doesn't it well you know
one of the things that I've heard you
say for years and years and years I
don't know if you're putting these words
or not but it's the theme is that that
you you teach people to be in control of
their money instead of their financial
problems being in control of them so
who's kind of driving driving the life
right and and and boundaries are
basically at the heart of of being in
control of yourself because boundaries
have to do with limits and and what all
of us have to realize every single day
is it we have limitations there are
boundaries we have so much time we have
so much energy there's only so many
things we can pour our lives and our
focus into there's only so much
resources today and if we are in control
and we're stewarding all of those things
we're setting the boundaries that define
the limits of what we're going to invest
in where we're going to spend it we can
be purposeful in spending our lives
instead of being the caboose in an
out-of-control train and I think Dave
what you've done in the financial world
for people is help them get in control
so that they can have purposeful eyes
that lead to good fruit and it's all
all you know there's so many boundaries
in there you know I can capsuled almost
in that saying where we talked about the
problem with my moneyz the guy in my
mirror that's right if I can get him to
behave he can be skinny and rich no it's
just it's it's that's the problem and
that's oh it's a boundary issue it
really does come down to that all right
Jenny is with us in Fresno California hi
Jenny your question for dr. Henry cloud
IJ hi dr. cloud thanks so much for
taking my call
hi Jenny so my question is how do you
know when it's okay or the right thing
to do to cut Grandparents out of your
child's life cut grandparents out of
your child's life you know Jenny it it
sounds like there's a story behind them
haha
you think oh yes because I don't think
it's like April 27th on some
grandparents calendars sounds like it
sounds like there's a context there is
there's quite a story so I'll make it
brief for you but basically my mother
plays a lot of you know her way or the
highway so she was happy when we were
planning a big wedding when we decided
to a small one because it was getting
out of control she couldn't be happy
enough to come so we didn't talk for a
while she didn't turn I know now cuz I
you know she said she couldn't be happy
even though she's and she liked the guy
because it's all about her Yeah right so
then now where's it read that she gets
two weddings in her life and you get
none cuz I think you had one didn't she
exactly so I'm alright I already don't
like this woman I'm sorry am I supposed
to say that out loud
hey just said that already oh you did
say that day so we tried again when we
had our sons you want to babysit one day
a week we said great but then she wasn't
consistent she wasn't learning morning's
were her best time so he said why don't
we do it at night and that way my dad
can come and we thought we were giving
up a big thing to give it one night a
week to have them over and she got so
mad we didn't hear from them again for a
long time and I reached out and said hey
you know are you said about this and
when we try to talk about it and they
said and we were attacking them so now I
have tried to reach out against another
couple of years and as soon as I say you
know if you want to move on you know try
to rectify the past or just leave it all
together she's like well of course I
want to tell them life
the story which is 5 and I don't want
all that poison or size being brought
into my son's life oh absolutely not
yeah well let me it is very painful
because one of the most important things
in the fabric of life are
multi-generational relationships it's
part of the fabric of what makes all of
life work and to whatever degree we can
we should have great multi-generational
relationships in the family now here I
would take your question originally like
when do you cut them out and I would
kind of flip it a little bit Jenny to to
this word I think that what boundaries
do is they end up where we don't cut
anybody out of our lives
people self-select out of our lives
because they don't want to accept the
boundaries that we've established for
ourselves ok so here's what I want you
to do in your head I want you to forget
that this is your mother or or anybody
else and say okay this is I'm a parent
okay
and whoever is going to be involved in
my child's life who's ever going to sit
in that chair the babies hitter chair
the teacher chair the mentor chair gonna
go to on my terms
they will do it with with the values of
my values that I'm trying to do for my
child now mom I hope that's you I really
want you to be involved in little
Susie's life but whoever is is going to
agree to fit into the schedule that's
good for Susie to talk about the things
that are helpful to Susie's development
to build into her what we think is
important to be built in her and mom I
hope that you if you can agree to that
we are going to be so happy if you can't
it really makes me sad because I'm going
to miss you right now what do you do if
she would fail that but you know behind
your back she's just going to be she's
violating your Binger side she's
violating the boundary you still have to
come back and that this has to be
enforced not only behind the back I mean
you you literally have to it says if you
were hiring a nanny that was
misbehaving right if to just just
disconnect from the mother stuff because
your mother is a travel agent for guilt
trips sign you up and I bet you've got
some frequent flyer miles - Jim and I
would hate to see with the upgrade I'm
not sure it's off so I mean yeah you
just it becomes a thing where she's a
very sad person who is really
debilitated by her inability to handle
boundaries and it becomes your
responsibility as a healthy mom to set
them for whoever is going to you
wouldn't let a nanny come into her life
in Mabuse er you wouldn't let a great
uncle that you wouldn't let a person as
a teacher violate that you wouldn't you
know your job is to set reasonable safe
thanks for the kid that's exactly right
and it is your job you are the steward
over this child's lives you know there
there's a verse in the Bible that says
that the parents are the guardians and
managers / children until they grow up
and one of the things you have to do in
all areas of life is you've got to guard
your child from influences that bend the
child in the wrong way and you've also
got to manage that process and and again
I would start with the big picture here
just like you're doing I'd write or
letter or send her an email or phone
call or say I want to have lunch and say
here's what I want in the big picture I
want us to be friends for until both of
us neither of us or one of us has gone
from the planet I want us to be close
but here's how it has to work for me and
then you tell me how it has to work for
you and we'll see if we can get those
together if we can't then like date says
just you know I'm sorry we'll miss you
we'll miss you and it's very sad it is
very very very sad but the problem in
this situation is I don't I mean she has
that option but apparently access to the
world runs through the top of her head
and so the whole thing spins around her
right and so and I if you really if you
really want to get depressed about this
which we're out of time
all right pick up my book necessary and
yeah that's that's okay and I've got a
chapter in there called the wise fool in
the evil and sometimes what we have to
realize is that sometimes there are
people as much love and as much feedback
as we give them they aren't listening in
what the Book of Proverbs is is they'll
actually shoot the messenger they do not
confront a mocker lest you incur insults
upon yourself and that's what's happened
so sometimes you have to say I've said
all I can say and in the conversation
the book is boundaries that book is
called necessary endings the author is
dr. Henry cloud if you don't have your
tickets the smart conference yet you
should get them at Dave Ramsey calm its
March the 29th that puts this particular
hour of the Dave Ramsey show and the
books
you
you